okay if I take Maedaku-san as my new girlfriend. Well
then, I'm Maedaku-san. It's more efficient and nice to date more people of the opposite sex at the same time. Besides, I'm
not dating you for the sake of efficiency, so let me
tell you.  Continuing my self-introduction Yes, medicine. I
love medicine in general. It's okay. I'm actually
worried because I'm a child. By the way, I look like
this because of the medicine, but I'm actually three
years my senior. My life has been ruined by the medicine.  I've
made a medicine for everyone today.
It's a medicine that will make your breasts bigger. What does it
mean? I don't need it. It's a
medicine that will make you less of a perverted person. What does it
mean? A medicine that will make you look a little more like a girl.  What is that? Where on earth did you get that
information? Where on earth did you do your research? I
heard it from Rentaro. It's the worst. It's the
worst. That's what I thought. I
hate Rentaro already. It's different. Rentaro
has an empty style.  I'm sorry for
saying that I'm cute when I'm not honest, but it's a lie.I do
n't really think I hate you at all.It hurt, but it's
okay.That's why I'm a Dom.